[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
you ever go like that you ever see
something so strange you just have to
the only reaction you can make is
[Music]
well there's a subreddit for that in
case you didn't know
things that make you go comments take
god damn it
all right i don't know if i've seen this
before i have not what
that is not real that is not real
if it's real i will literally whom the
hell out of it
so cute
i haven't homed yet to be honest ice
cube ice cube recipes
how can i make one of those hmm i don't
know
i guess i gotta google it that can't be
real this is just me going that can't be
real
there's no way oh
it took me a while it took me a while to
get them
oh i'm on the wrong reddit this is the
real one
hmm what the hell is that oh it's madoka
girls that's a good anime i recommend it
uh it can recommend it to me i gotta
save that madoka girls check it out
what uh oh hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
no that's so cute cop out
mr douglas i don't remember the name
because i don't care because i'm an
adult and i don't care about harry
potter thank you
oh oh
disgusting
that's genius i want those give me those
can you imagine being mark zuckerberg
you're trying to be quirky and weird
online like you make these live streams
where you're grilling
and you go nice job team and then the
entire internet makes fun of you for
being socially awkward
so then you leave the internet right
ironically the guy that created social
media leaves the internet
and there's one photo leaked of him
looking awkward and the internet makes
fun of him again
it's beautiful never change the internet
i have a lot of questions about this one
but i don't think there will ever be
answers
oh forbidden forbidden smooth
zero coke i want it look at ron's face
dude
he's as impressed as anyone did anyone
else point that out
no one saw it that's crazy i mean hmm
hmm
i mean honestly why why not
that makes sense
[Laughter]
no i like that image i'll save that
oh my god
papa franco nice nicer
oh that's so weird what is that
forbidden tambourine must smack it
forbidden chinese tambourine or is it
yeah it is
one gang crying crying walk and cry
let's join ceiling gang now what gang or
stop crying [ __ ]
it's the same chair side is this you
this you bro i actually used to do this
i used to save my red bull cans when i
was like
14. i thought it was so cool to drink
red bull that i
i saved my cans anyway now i have my own
energy drink
twenty percent off no wait ten percent
uh is it ten percent up i don't remember
enter the code and see if something
happens pewdiepie
it's legit that it tastes way better
than red bull and i'm not just saying
that it really does
and it's way more healthy i don't know
if it is but i think it is
it has to be now they could sue me if i
say something but [ __ ] it i'll say it
it's made out of
balls from bulls and that's gay which is
nothing wrong with
it's just gay hmm
i'm saving these i [ __ ] love pictures
like this
this one goes to my home folder oh
harambe no
go back go back to sleep
what is that real no
you're a big guy
no one cared who i was until i put on
the milk
oh i've seen this this is from higurashi
it's no big deal all right
all right all right yeah that's that's
cool that's cool
that's not him which country do you
think this is
oh my god america are you okay
i feel like america need a win it's been
a while
you're a big guy you were a big guy now
you're not
oh my god is that real why would you do
that why
what's that flavor um
tastes like indian scams
that's a home that's a home i wonder
what that tastes like honestly
i'll smoke some milk hey bro you want
you want to go to my house we can smoke
some milk i gotta
gotta find find pack of milk at home you
want to go smoke it
oh well you don't dip your
oreos in salsa cringe that's not
that's delicious that's delicious and
good and tasty
oh god damn oh hell yeah
i wonder whether he got an idea like
that
who would be such an idiot hmm no
i have a lot of questions i have lots of
humming
someone did this and i respect you i
respect you so much whoever did this
oh my god i wish i could do that on my
figurine that'd be so good
does the head not come off or with this
the legs comes out
[Laughter]
i like it it's better this way get your
figurine out
pewdiepie that store i've seen these
those are meson
my my geniera or whatever it's called
they're like
500 pounds i actually wanted to buy them
because then i could just look down and
always go hmm am i right or am i right
i told you bro 600 pounds
i'm not buying that i ain't [ __ ] mine
that no way
hell
oh why god
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your gas bro 180 miles per hour
that's my guess well i guess it breaks
my heart to confirm
that ronald mcdonald is a goddamn ship
no god damn it no
oh it landed on my ah
i'll slap the [ __ ] oh what oh it's from
china
nice nice one i get it oh hell yeah
that's not a that's a [ __ ] yeah that's a
cool fan art i like that
over half a billion animals have been
killed in australia
kylie jenner also kelly jenner 1 000
euro mink fur
[Music]
wait are you saying kylie jenner no not
kylie jenner she can't be a hypocrite
no
[Laughter]
jack stratton how i made it 290 000
selling books
only one left in stock that's actually
dope i legit want it dope fire man
water man hmm this door handle fits
perfectly into this hole in the wall
nah that's just [ __ ] crazy all right
give me some good hum
give me give me a good finish humps is
that minecraft
i respect it hmm of approval
how to break into a house fans broke
into my house
[Laughter]
that's a good one
oh my god tank museum monkey world
nuclear power plant
spider farm i think i will not go there
all right guys hope you had a good hmm
if you home the once this video smash
hmm
on this video check out simp merch
it's up right now buy it now before
scythe buys
the entire stock i'm gonna go have lunch
and i'll see you guys tomorrow hey there
subscribe
subscribe we're trying to hit 107
million subscribers
thank you for subscribing yeah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean